The Internet lost its (bleep)
last night
over some salacious new gossip
generated by BuzzFeed
about President-Elect
Donald Trump.
The explosive leak
is unverified.
-(laughter)
-Uh, we don't know if it's true.
Now I have to say,
we were working
last night when this broke.
I didn't really get all
the details-- I'm really busy--
but I honestly
don't see what the big deal is.
Everybody loves
The Golden Girls.
-What is the problem?
-(laughter)
It's especially...
What's the big deal?
-(cheers and applause)
-Yeah. Right?
Oh.
And if they're peeing on you,
even better.
(laughter and groaning)
At a press conference
this morning, Trump confirmed
via catchphrase that his sons
will be running his companies.
I hope at the end of eight
years, I'll come back,
and I'll say,
"Oh, you did a good job."
Otherwise, if they do a bad job,
I'll say, "You're fired."
-(laughter)
-I see he did the, uh...
It's the thing he said
on the thing.
-(laughter)
-He also...
He also promised reporters
his inauguration would be
"very, very elegant."
Instead of popular A-listers
and artists
that millions of people
would be interested in seeing,
his planner said
he'll be surrounded
with "soft sensuality."
A "soft sensuality."
I don't know. Maybe like
a nice, romantic dinner at home
with Mike Huckabee
in a velvet robe.
-(laughter)
-That's very soft.
And sensual.
Don't neglect the Huckabees.
Uh, comedians, with all
this craziness surrounding
our golden leader, how exactly
is Trump's inauguration
going to be elegant?
Emily?
He's gonna swear
on a solid gold bible
that encrusted
in Swarovski crystals,
but it'll be the size of,
you know, like,
-a cereal box you get at a diner
so that, uh... -(laughter)
...you know, so that
his little hand looks real big.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Okay, points.
-(applause)
-Points. Matt Kirshen.
Uh, it'll smell
like the finest asparagus.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
Points. Rhys.
Thanks, everybody.
(laughter)
-Ah. -Very good.
HARDWICK: Yes. I'm so sorry.
It must of been hard
for you to start talking
from that thunderous round
of applause.
(laughter)
What's...?
We've got a good four years
ahead of us.
I think
this large red button will
launch my fireworks display.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Okay.
Oh.
(imitates explosion)
(laughter)